les moyens mis en œuvre au fil de
l'évolution par les plantes afin de se
disséminer sont
étonnants parmi eux il en est un des
plus simples mais qui a fait ses preuves
la noix de coco en est l'exemple le plus
connu un certain nombre de plantes ont
opté comme elle pour la
natation en effet quoi de plus simple
que de se laisser porter par la mer vers
de nouveaux rivages mais encore faut-il
être bien préparé à ce genre de voyage
non seulement les graines doivent
flotter mais elles doivent avoir la peau
dure pour résister au sel
marin c'est le cas du bois jaune les
graines dures et épaisses sont entouré
de fibres serrées qui constittu une
sorte de
Boué le bois jaune pousse dans les zones
dem sèche et les forêts humides de
moyenne et basse altitude de l'île de la
Réunion jusqu'à 1200
m il peut atteindre une douzaine de
mètres de
haut il est très ramifié et son écorce
est gris
foncé les feuilles allongées étroites et
pointues à l'extrémité sont accrochées
au même droit sur les branches par trois
ou qure c'est un moyen de le reconnaître
facilement à partir du mois d'octobre
les fleurs apparaissent à l'extrémité
des branches mais c'est surtout entre le
mois de janvier et février qu'elles
exaltent leur parfum à travers la forêt
attirant les polinisateurs et surtout
les papillons de
nuit
elle pouss en bouquet souvrant l'une
après l'autre dressée au-dessus du
feuillage
elle ressemble à s méprendre à des
fleurs de frangip paniier en
miniature les cœurs Grenat se détachent
sur les corolles blanches en hélice
indiquant la direction du nectare
convoité malgré les nombreuses fleurs
qui couvrent les arbres
peu de fruits se forment deux ou trois
seulement vont grossir suspendus à une
petite tige ils sont relativement gros 3
à 4 cm en forme d'amande ils murissent
doucement en attendant de
tomber qui pouvait bien se régaler de
ces graines des perroquets des tortues
on ne le saura sans doute jamais les
animaux qui ont participé à l'évolution
de nombreuses espèces de plantes sur
l'île de la Réunion ont disparu
emportant avec eux de nombreux
mystères